Ronni the limo drivers gonna be so mad
out of me why because I'm gonna bust his
balls right now
well then sit back and relax no I mean
I'm in my listen I'm a lucky guy get to
ride around on a limousine yes and I'm
you know I'm gonna pay for the privilege
but nevertheless a limousine is just a
car that's stretched out right and the
first car I ever owned was a 1970
valiant the amazing thing about this car
had this spectacular feature if you were
hot you could put on the air-conditioner
and if you were cold put on heat and
this was amazing to me that I could sit
in a car and I came to found out that
every car has this so this maniac Ronnie
the limo driver who by the way will
never ever buy another limo for you for
me never I will go out and buy the limo
what has he done now sit in the back of
the car when I was out Saturday night it
was cold out so I go to put the heat on
and sometimes he takes a second to come
on it's blowing cold air I said just be
patient the heat will come on we're
freezing now more because now cold air
switch this is heat yeah and has air
conditioning low and behold I put down
the window and I and I say to my driver
the [ __ ] going on I'm freezing back
here I'm free he goes no no don't you
remember ronnie has a converter in there
like at a certain point he has to switch
it to air conditioning and another time
used to switch it to heat building yeah
I was gonna say in October every
building in Manhattan goes to heat how
do you have a [ __ ] car in America
it's the only [ __ ] car that I know of
I can't have I have to decide what is it
explain tight
what's going on here's what happened do
you remember you we had problem with the
air conditioning wasn't blowing cold
remember what yeah yeah hold why is that
all right so what they did was they went
back to the old system they used to use
years ago before they had climate
control on these things because it's
separated from the front to the back
okay you follow any of this it's two
separate units
[ __ ] you you don't understand I'm trying
to you would you say [ __ ] you Donna
because Ronnie there's not a car in
America that doesn't have heating
air-conditioning them alright so here's
what you do I want you to go today and
tell this guy who in America has a car
that doesn't have air conditioning and
heat the SIP I could go by I can't
simultaneously in the summertime here's
what I have to build the fireplace back
ask Ralph he's been in there Ralph am I
making this [ __ ] up
hey now yeah no dude this is from day
one I know after that disastrous other
limo right Ronny how do you switch a
towed around could you just say how do
you switch it over by the switch what
what date did you decide I should start
being cold take out of the car when did
you switch over I wanted when it turned
like 75 80 degrees all right now under
the hood is a valve that I have to shut
off it's like a little Ted [ __ ] well one
and that keeps it keeps it keeps the
antifreeze from flowing to the back of
the car so you get cold air but why is
it every car in America every limo in
America has hot and cold I just and
you're the only [ __ ] guy that has 20
different times tell the guy what point
is he gonna give the money back the car
doesn't work well can't you change the
petcock according to the weather so I
can go out and get a different car why'd
it was Rome out I didn't realize it was
gonna get cold I tell you what why don't
you switch the steering wheel how's this
for an answer to the back and I'll tell
you what you could sit in the back and
drive and I'll sit up front with this
dude do you know how embarrassing it is
to ride in a limousine with my family or
my fiance and I'm paying all this money
and I'm mr. fancy mr. bigshot I got a
limousine and I turn on the [ __ ] heat
there's no and then the driver goes oh
you remember we had a switch over and I
mean
my girlfriend is laughing at me she goes
you gotta be kidding remember do you
remember she does it have he don't
expect heat now you remember when you've
gotten out of the car and gotten under
the hood and stuff with me 15 minute oh
that would have been great did you have
a crank in the firm the cars get it
going no I mean what is this can I ask a
quick question Ronny yeah if it's just a
matter of turning this petcock right how
come whoever was driving Howard that
night didn't know how to do it he knows
how to do it I don't know why because it
was a 15 minute or 20 minute drive he's
gonna go on under the hood with a
flashlight and start and pull all these
don't have to go on right oh stop I want
to change that from scores man to limo
man and concentrate what you're supposed
to be oh shut up Ralph go [ __ ] watch
TV what the [ __ ] do you do Ronnie it's
kind it's not
I don't you have I don't [ __ ] I've
been I've been down to like the most
remote locations like I've been down
like it's like a port on an island where
guys got a beat-up limo you know they
don't have good carpet line they got air
conditioning you got heat don't ask if
they got at all I'm the only guy I think
in America's got a [ __ ] petcock I
just need heat that's all I'm sorry
don't tell you just need heat no no I
need heat any air-conditioning rod Roddy
let me clarify come back here
I need heat and air conditioning not
just he don't reset the petcock